The joe rogan experience.
Oh yeah.
Forgot to tell you this.
What?
So when I was,
I was having some pretty good thoughts
on this acid watching some different
pants.
The killers by the way,
fucking killed it.
Hmm.
Um,
so I've tried,
you see stuff in like when you're out
there on second dog,
so truth,
I call them universal truths where you
just like,
yes,
that is real.
That is right.
100%.
And it's hard to bring that shit back
into this realm,
you know,
to understand it and trying to get us
kicked off youtube.
It's passing car.
So it's hard when you come back to be
like,
oh,
I saw the truth of something and then
it's like I,
and you can't express it.
And when people come back,
when they're around you,
they say something and you're like,
what?
And they're like,
they realized that get frustrated.
They're not saying it right.
And then it's slowly going away.
Yeah.
So when I was there in that place,
sometimes I try to remember like when
you get back say this to this person,
so that state told me to tell you the M
and m is one of the realest MCS.
I'm not going to argue with it.
I don't know
what exactly
but it was like does that could be a
funny bit dude.
There's a funny bit in there like about
how like some things are just in the
moment.
They seem so profound and then I'd be
like,
what the fuck is wrong with me?
And My name was one of the real estate
MCS.
Why would agree with that?
Oh,
so he's very,
very real.
It seems fairly
brill and leary almost certainly played
a role,
but I think it's slightly ironic that
he's a journalist and didn't really go
that deep into the role that journalists
played in all of this,
which was humongous.
You know,
journalists are sculptors of public
opinion and it became the standard way
of reporting on any of these things to
say that they're bad,
to sensationalize it and to not have any
consideration for what that would do.
Because anytime a journalist writes him
scare story,
they can really mess with drug policy in
a serious way.
It might seem like nothing like,
oh,
there's a bunch of people in Brooklyn
and they overdosed on some obscure
synthetic cannabinoid amb food Bendeka
who cares about amb food?
Banika no big deal.
Say that it turns people into zombies
and if it gets thrown into schedule one,
who cares?
Not a big deal.
Well,
that's a very short sighted way of
thinking about all of this because
that's exactly what happened with
psychedelics and then we're not learning
from the mistakes of the past that just
because something,
it's fun to sensationalize and talk
about how dangerous it is at this
moment.
It doesn't mean that 10 years from now
we're going to recognize that it has
serious therapeutic potential and we
made a big mistake outlawing it.
And I think a lot of that also comes
from this sort of us versus them
mentality that people have where it's
cannabis is good.
Synthetic cannabinoids are bad.
Well,
synthetic cannabinoids don't have to be
bad for cannabis to be good.
Cannabis can be good without something
else being bad to counter balance.
You don't need to hate something to
justify your love of cannabis.
And this whole hatred of synthetic
cannabinoids I think is totally
misdirected because these are products
of prohibition that most people wouldn't
even want to use in the first place.
And when they do use them,
they don't know what they're taking.
They don't know what dose they're
consuming.
And so of course they're having bad
experiences that would happen with
almost any drug.
Caffeine included if people just
consumed enormous unmeasured doses
without having any idea what they were
getting into.
And so they're thrown into schedule one.
What happens if 30 years from now,
once the therapeutic potential of
cannabinoids is being really seriously
explored,
we find out that that Ambi [inaudible]
that everyone was saying turn homeless
people into zombies in Brooklyn in 2017
turns out to activate a certain subtype
of the CB one receptor that's especially
useful for Parkinson's disease or
something like that.
Then we're going to regret having done
that.
So I think people have to be very
careful.
Anytime you say anything negative about
a drug,
you have to be very,
very careful because the implications
can be enormous.
I think that the best stance and all of
this is to not speak ill of drug,
any drug.
The drugs have breakthrough drug
enthusiasm.
But also if you really think about the
fact that we are in a world where people
have to go to work to do a job,
that by the way,
man,
if there is a dude you need to get on
this podcast and there's a book that you
would love,
David Graber wrote this book called
Bullshit Jobs.
This guy is a fucking genius man.
And this book,
bullshit jobs breaks down the phenomena
of,
uh,
how many,
many people are working in jobs that
don't do anything for the world or the
company they're working for.
And it's not like this judgmental thing
where he's like,
yeah,
that's a bullshit job.
You're a blah,
blah,
blah.
He's one of the,
he's like an anthropologist.
So he's very precise.
But one of the qualifications for your
job to be a bullshit job is you know,
that it's really kind of a worthless
job.
It's not really doing anything.
And like the companies have gotten so
fucking big that uh,
they,
they end up having like departments or
people running departments or extra
employees that don't really need to be
there at all and they have to pretend to
be to work.
That's what he writes about.
He writes it,
if you really want to torture a person,
uh,
not only give them like the job of like,
you know,
pouring a glass of water and an empty
glass and pouring it back,
but then add to it,
did they have to deceive their boss into
thinking that they're like doing an
important job or they lose their job.
So these not only are these,
like some corporations and companies
scanning your pis to see if you're
taking a substance that is allowing you
to connect with home what you actually
are.
They are demanding that you spend many
hours a day lying to them,
that you're doing work that you're not
doing.
Like,
if you're fucking efficient,
you know,
and this is another thing I graybar
writes about,
forgive me David Graver.
If in any way I'd misconstrue this,
I read your writings stoned,
but the,
and,
the,
um,
the other fucking element to it that is
absolutely atrocious and fucking
horrible is that,
uh,
these substances are connecting is to
home.
They don't want us to be in those states
and they're asking us to fucking lie all
day.
And you know what psychedelic means?
The etymology of psychedelic.
No,
it means mind manifesting or sole
manifesting,
right?
So a psychedelic connects us potentially
with the truth,
what we are,
our identity,
right?
And these companies,
they're asking us to lie,
to be the opposite of our identities,
to wear weird a suit or,
or some kind of dress code.
And to sit in a desk where,
because you're efficient,
you get your job done in 45 minutes and
for the next six hours you got to sit
and
type in,
pretend that you're working.
It was an ongoing maneuver of mine.
We'd have these hippie writers come in
to take notes and I'd say,
yeah,
I played this fender stratocaster as I
hold up my Gibson Birdland,
which was known for,
and they'd write down,
he played in a Gibson a stratocaster.
There's no such thing as the gifts
reddick guest.
So I was having fun with dirt bag anti
journalists.
So now I'm invited to high times
magazine and I was hardcore anti-drug.
So I go in and this guy is and here's
typically,
uh,
so uh,
tell me about a GSI amboy Dukes,
what is it?
Like a band?
And I went,
yeah,
it's like a band.
So it's almost exactly like a band kind
of a question.
Is this,
how did this all started still draft
Sony?
How we started talking about when I'm
with the MC five and the stooges and we
would party and I go,
yeah man,
I was snorting something.
I don't know what it was,
man,
I just got higher than a kite.
And he goes,
wow,
you think I might've been a crystal
meth?
And I mean,
yeah,
that's what they called it.
I never snorted crystal meth and ups and
shit just went nuts.
And I,
we went into the war thing and I go,
I don't know anything about war.
I'm a,
I'm a guitar player.
But I went down from my draft physical
and when I went into the booth to give
my urine sample,
I made sure I ate Mexican food all week.
So instead of pissing in the Urine Cup,
I took a big dump in it was green and
went all over the place and the guy
went,
wow.
He really,
yeah,
really.
And so I made up the story for High
Times magazine,
you know,
the great magazine of good information
and uh,
embed.
It turned out that my drummer,
Kj night,
God bless him,
he,
Jack,
she admitted this in and testified that
that's what he did.
We thought it was the funniest thing in
the world.
We're teenagers and this guy went into
the draft physical,
just an absolute near death,
lumpy shit to get out of the draft.
And we thought it was funnier and hell.
We weren't paying attention to important
things in life.
And so the,
the Ted Hating liberal press started
quoting the high times magazine and
quoting an ex girlfriend who claimed
that I adopted her,
did her,
I adopted my girlfriend.
If you read that one,
I did read that one.
I forgot about it.
So this kind of stuff,
I was like,
you adopted her so you could take her on
tour with Ya know,
so I could fucker,
that's what the story was.
But that's Ab.
Absolutely.
I don't think that's how it works.
That's not,
I don't think it makes it easier to talk
than once you adopt them.
I didn't adopt anybody.
I never shit my pants since I was eight
months old.
Um,
I've never been with an underage girl
since I was under age.
I'm not a racist.
And what else do they say?
Oh,
and they seem that they claimed that I
made Courtney love blow me when she was
12.
I think she claimed that I,
yeah,
I never met Courtney love.
You can tell I don't have a rash.
Um,
you just gotta be kidding me.
They just make this shit up because they
know I'm so good at bringing my basic
conservative agenda forward that they
have to go full,
solid Lynskey and lie and lie and lie.
And if you go to Wikipedia to find out
about Ted Nugent,
they will repeat these lies.
They're lies.
Every one of those things.
If I had done and I go,
yeah,
it was awesome,
but I didn't do any of those things.
Anyone can edit wikipedia,
you know that right in the balls.
Very strange that she might have edited
it yet.
So,
so I'm glad we got that.
Oh,
this thing is just persisted forever.
Obviously it stuck in your crop because
you wanted to bring it up,
but the very end,
it doesn't stick in my crotch.
Just,
it's a fascinating example of the
dishonesty and the anti journalism
agenda driven,
um,
anti American anti Ted Anti Second
Amendment,
anti freedom buffoonery the exist.
I think it makes for an interesting
podcast exchange.
I think so.
It's not in my craw.
It's not even in my universe,
but I notice it.
It's hysterical.
Yeah.